[Music]
[Applause]
he is the former Arizona Cardinal GM
Steve Keim you can check out draft Night
Live FOX Sports radio I Heart Radio app
coming up Thursday at 8 Eastern through
the first round of the draft you'll have
Steve there with Jay Glazer and LaVar
Arrington Rob Stone will be your host
pick by pick predictions reactions to
every first round pick Steve let me
start with uh first of all thanks for
joining us what you think Arizona will
do with the number three pickup what
would you do if you were still the GM of
the Cardinals
well I think it's certain the situation
that we're in right now today and I I
think that there's a good chance that
they would trade back uh that being said
uh it's easier said than done because of
the situation when you're sitting there
number three you have to have a trade
partner obviously the the trade has to
work for both parties and there has to
be a player that the other team wants to
come up for so uh generally that's a
quarterback at that point in time but uh
if they get locked in I think that they
should probably go past Russian Will
Anderson to me is the pick there okay
but when you're trying to explore a
trade like that are you thinking about
the other team
they the other are you have you ever
gone into a trade trying to flee
somebody
I mean I obviously you uh you want to
come out on top but at the same time the
other team to make that trade has to
have a lot of urgency to them uh
especially to come up to that position
and to give up that much uh draft
Capital so it to me it's not as hard
yeah I wonder about that with GM's we we
heard both GM's yesterday with Green Bay
and also the Jets you know they were
complementary of each other that they
got a deal done your reaction let's
let's start with what the Jets gave up
to get Aaron Rodgers what did you make
of that uh side of this trade I thought
when you sit there and you're in a
position that the jets are in and Joe
Douglas is looking at a football team
that's extremely talented but doesn't
have a quarterback of that magnitude I
think that you got to get what you got
to give up is is well worth it again I
always think this Dan when you wake up
in the morning and you have a
quarterback that you think can take you
to the promised land
um take do what it takes to get them and
there's probably only eight or nine guys
in the NFL that you wake up feeling that
way about and if you're the Green Bay
Packers obviously you get a lot of draft
Capital but at the same time you're
sitting there saying who is our
franchise quarterback moving forward and
if it is uh the young man that's
currently there why didn't you make that
change prior to uh this point in time
you know you drafted them in the first
round so there has to be some questions
of whether they have the amount of
confidence in him yeah I would have
moved on from Rogers prior to last
season even though he's played great I I
have to find out if Jordan love can play
and and where is this franchise headed
and it felt like Rogers was controlling
the franchise instead of the other way
around
and it felt like he had too much power
in there but you don't want to be known
as the GM who traded away Aaron Rodgers
unless you really know what you're going
to have in the ACT what would your
expectations be for Green Bay this year
well you know again I think it comes
down to what is their confidence in in
the quarterback that they have in love
you know it's again they know enough
about him he's been there long enough uh
obviously Matt leflora knows how to use
him and has a good way of understanding
his strengths and his weaknesses but
again at the same time they're in a
situation with the salary cap and moving
on from a player that you know they can
clear that much space with that they
have to be thinking a little bit that
they're going to the youth movement
which for them to me has to be a
situation where they can't be as
confident about making the playoffs but
the Jets don't make this move unless
they think they can win a Super Bowl
is that right you have to right but
again but again it's like the movie Tin
Cup when you're in a situation where
you're Joe Douglas and Robert Salah you
can't lay up anymore Dan you're in a
position where you got to make something
happen particularly in a market like New
York
what was your scouting report on Rogers
I mean he had all the talent in the
world I mean off the charts in terms of
his his accuracy his velocity all the
things he saw him in an NFL player but
what did you try to make him do what
would what would be his weakness
his weakness would be sometimes getting
careless with the ball a guy that has so
much confidence in their arm talent that
they can let it get away from them at
times and play a little loose but at the
same time I know at that time there are
a lot of questions about why Alex Smith
went number one and he fell so far
do you remember your scouting report on
Jordan love or did you even have one
yeah I mean I again I thought he was a
guy that you could project and you could
you could forecast that there was some
Talent there but and you know to me
looking at all the other top
quarterbacks that I've done over the
years he wasn't a guy that I thought was
a guaranteed lock as an NFL starter
so you didn't have a first round grade
on Jordan love no we didn't
um
take me back to the Kyler Murray do you
remember when you saw him with me in my
interview I did with him at the Super
Bowl in Atlanta and did that did that
impact you like what was the
conversation like when you saw him not
answering any questions and really uh
kind of an embarrassing moment yeah I
mean I know he was overwhelmed at that
point in time and uh that was important
for us after seeing that to get to sit
down and know him as a person and to be
able to feel like he could become
himself and you know really wonder why
he got so uptight in that situation and
again I think that throughout the
process we got to know him fairly well
um it was an interesting uh conversation
when it came down to whether we're going
to take him or Nick Bosa which has
turned out to be a phenomenal player and
that's the fun process of The Scouting
game is the evaluation part of it and
not just who's a better player what's a
better fit for your organization at that
point in time if I gave you a do-over
will calamari got me an extension Nick
Bosa probably would have got me fired
really
well I mean your quarterback position is
the guy who can Propel your team the
quickest
yeah but and he did that
okay
could Nick Bose have got us to an 11 win
team that year two years ago yeah I mean
that's fair that's fair
um would you have given him that
extension if I gave you a do-over
uh yes you would yeah and it's because I
still believe in the young man and
because supply and demand at that
position either you have one or you
don't and whether they all have
questions and holes you have to be able
to you're either in or you're out you
can't play the middles on these
situations
well I I
and a couple of you guys because I
thought you went in a year early like he
he called your bluff and then you guys
gave him a pretty damn good contract uh
and I I'm just not sold on him I think
he's exciting I think football came easy
to him because he's athletic but look
you guys put something in his contract
just to we need you to understand there
are a lot of great everybody's great in
the NFL
um and who came up with the idea to put
a clause in there basically saying we
need you to do your homework well I'll
just say it's an organizational decision
and the real big thing about it is when
you give that kind of money Dan you got
to hold people accountable and I know
it's a touch but you shouldn't have to
put it in their contract though Steve
right right well there's a lot of things
in contract that maybe you shouldn't
have to put in there you know if you
really look at the big picture but you
got to hold everybody accountable and
both sides are protected
do you think he's still a franchise
quarterback
I do I think he's got because again you
have to look at supply and demand I keep
going back to that I my first year as GM
I traded for Carson Palmer and obviously
it worked out extremely well for a
seventh round draft pick and then after
that you know when you don't have Carson
Palmer anymore it's easier said than
done then let's go get one you know Joe
Douglas until he's gotten Aaron Rodgers
now what were they doing you know it's
eight quarterbacks and then really you
know it's it's a it's a game of musical
chairs there aren't enough good
quarterbacks out there that's the bottom
line who would you have to swing okay
how many quarterbacks
have a first round grade not that we'll
go in the first round how many how many
this draft in my opinion in this draft
uh three three first round graders on
three okay correct but there's gonna be
more than three go and that's going to
be because of supply and demand yeah
there'll be five that'll probably go
right I mean Hendon hookers 25 coming
off an ACL and he could go you know to
Minnesota late in the first round and
you've got to understand when we did the
Kyla Murray contract we took him number
one overall he fit with Cliff King's
very didn't schematically and at the end
of the day he was a rookie of the year
and back-to-back Pro Bowl play uh
back-to-back All Pro I know that's not
everything but it's pointing in the
right direction to give you the faith
that he's going to get there what did
you see in Josh Rosen
Josh Rosen was a guy that again in that
draft class all those guys that went
before him uh were highly graded and we
got to the point where we were sitting
at 15 and we he was the highest rated
player at that position on the board so
again if you don't take one you'll never
know and sometimes you just have to
swing and we all know whether it's a
quarterback or not first round picks
analytics say the last 10 years and 49
of those guys don't work out that's
that's a huge number yeah that
regardless of position whether it's you
know considering the best position uh on
the field that's most important 49 give
me your red flag on the field though at
that position
or quarter player in particular no just
just that a bill has to be nowadays
ability to process and see things to be
able to anticipate you know a lot of
these guys the more that we see are guys
that are athletic players that can get
out of trouble with their feet uh
comparable to the Past well they still
have to be able to process see things
and be able to anticipate and that's
harder to find and it's harder to see it
as an evaluator than it is to see the
physical tools yeah I was wondering that
that you know you have tests now this
this new test that's not the Wonderlic
but it is testing in real time how you
react uh to seeing something and but
there are a lot of people love Josh
Rosen because he had some some Swagger
and uh had that unbelievable comeback at
UCLA it why didn't he why didn't he work
I mean I felt bad for him because the
offensive line right did not do him any
favors but what what did he miss yeah
you know that's that's a great question
and uh you know really looking back at
it sometimes uh you know he had all the
tools he's a smart guy a very uh
intellectual but sometimes it's it's the
commitment off the field whether it's
the time you know with his uh teammates
on the practice field you know whether
it's he's is the fact is is he a
football junker he doesn't does he do it
because he likes it or because he loves
it and to me that's the thing that
separates the great ones yeah you know
is the fact that they're either obsessed
and they live for it or do they do it
because it's it's something they're
pretty good at well that's why I wonder
about Tom Brady you know was Tom Brady
destined to be a great quarterback or
did he become a great quarterback
because he he was consumed with the game
you know Peyton was going to be a high
draft pick first round pick one overall
had lineage there but he also consumed
the game yeah it meant everything to him
trying to trying to measure that Steve
how difficult is that to find out just
how much this guy loves playing football
right and I think you you nailed it on
the head man I mean if you're if you're
the first pick in the draft you were
destined probably to be it in the long
as long as you have the obsession and
the will will want to but if you're a
six-round pick you just nailed it with
Tom Brady I mean I think he willed
himself to become a great player and one
of the best of all time
it wasn't like he was drafted because of
his physical skills no no that's I mean
it's it's weird that you can kind of
make yourself into being a great player
at that position it's how much time are
you going to put in uh Bijan Robinson I
love him
I don't know in today's NFL like how
much can you love him at that position
well again you know just just to date
back to the analytics and our our
analytics team in Arizona told us that
the best backs uh that had the most
success in the NFL were drafted between
rounds three and five
so as a NFL GM you want to be very weary
I think of taking a guy that high yet at
the same time there have been some
special backs like Adrian Peterson that
warranted that high of a pick it's just
you can you get your arms wrapped around
putting a player that plays that
position and takes that kind of abuse
and generally those guys don't last
beyond one or two contracts yeah but you
know what that's a different era with
Adrian Peterson I mean we're seeing
Derrick Henry as sort of the last uh you
know he's a dinosaur here everybody else
that's why I like Bijan Robinson and
Scout told me if if you can make him
into a Debo Samuel type where put him in
the slot uh McCaffrey type like that's
that's where we're going we're not
loading up running backs and you're
gonna run 25 30 times a game right and
that's the one thing that's evaluated
you have to assess and individually say
is that what makes that guy special when
you do watch Bijan Robinson he does look
like a natural slot receiver when he
does that and he does have all those
other compensating factors to his game
yeah right he's a fascinating Talent how
real is the movie draft day
it's actually probably one of the most
accurate movies I've seen that you know
in regards to NFL football football and
general Sports it's actually it's well
done
what makes it so accurate
I just think the storyline and the way
the conversations go behind the scenes I
mean other than the fact that Kevin
Costner is a lot more handsome than I am
but but you know you're asking about
this quarterback of why nobody went to
his party like would you actually try to
find those things out
I mean that is a huge red flag yes it
really is and there are things that do
come up like that that are real head
shakers and it's why the draft process
is so fun because here we are so late in
this process day and that we've done all
this homework and it's really the season
to overthink you know it's like you fall
in love with a guy in the fall and then
you confuse yourself in the spring
yeah
and you see these GMS and owners like
how difficult is that when you do your
job like Jerry Jones Jerry Jones the
owner Jerry Jones the GM two different
people and you almost have to say Jerry
let me take care because he wanted to
take Johnny Manziel the GM wanted to you
know Jerry the GM wanted to take Johnny
Manziel and you're like yeah so how
difficult is that that you do all this
work and then you're going to have
somebody above you that goes I want that
guy well that can happen I think you
know in most situations when you're the
general manager you should have a good
enough relationship with your owner
where you sort of set those
conversations uh they start much earlier
and generally the ownership ownership is
is on board with those sort of decisions
and and they're made together but at the
same time and again that's what's fun
about this thing it's because you you
never know how it's going to go again we
haven't played football since January in
at the college level why are guys stocks
rising in and plummeting
because they ran a slow three cone no
you know what it is mock drafts
mock drafts build these kids up to a
certain level and then once the
professionals come in and start getting
to see them breaking stuff down then
they start to drop so is CJ Stroud
dropping or is he going to end up where
he should the media put him up that high
yeah yeah I mean I think again it goes
back to what's the evaluation on them
and at this time of year they sort of
stay strong in the inside the war room
it's the outside part of it that he's
dropped now again the problem for GMS is
you've got to make sure that you stay
out of The Fray there you've got to keep
tunnel vision you can't listen to all
that because you will overthink it if
you don't
have fun on Thursday yeah it's like you
said I'm sitting there getting ready to
make a decision I love this quarterback
why in the hell did nobody go to his
party
did you ever have a red flag like that
with a player without the name
where you found out
something like that
yeah I mean and it was a red flag like
this I had a very close friend on that
staff and I was going to take this
player with a very very high pick and
I'll never forget the night before the
draft I called him just to make myself
feel better one more time
and I said coach is there any reason if
you were me why you wouldn't do this and
he said
uh and I write then Dan said oh boy I
didn't even do that I want a conviction
to him say hell no take him is he
signaling to you without telling you yes
because he doesn't want to be you know
you don't want any paper trail where
he's ratting out a player so it's
correct yeah okay so and in this day and
age don't ignore red flags
can we guess the name of the player
no okay uh have fun on Thursday if you
and Glazer get into a wrestling match
who's winning
Place yeah I've been on vacation man I'm
way too out of shape yeah yeah Glazer
he's still he's ready to go in the
Octagon yeah you know he breaks stories
and breaks next uh have fun on Thursday
night Steve thanks for joining us thanks
Dan enjoy the Man Steve kind former
Arizona GM draft Night Live on Fox
Sports Radio I Heart Radio Thursday
night star studded it'll be Jay Glazer
it'll be Steve Khan it'll be the College
Football Hall of Famer Lamar Arrington
and the popular Rob Stone will be your
host pick by pick and predictions as
well